d'ici quelques minutes je vous le disais
dans le sommet il ya un autre ministre
sur y en a de même deux autres qui sont
sous les feux de la rampe il ya jean
yves le drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères et son homologue la ministre
des armées florence parly les deux sont
à moscou il ya en ce moment un conseil
de coopération sur les questions de
sécurité
si on suivait pas de trop près les
affaires internationales on pouvait
penser que la france et la russie était
un peu fâché mais tout ça c'est fini
ecoutez jean yves le drian il l'a
affirmé tout à l'heure et le moment est
venu le moment est propice pour
travailler à réduire la défiance entre
la russie et l'europe qui devrait des
partenaires sur le plan stratégique et
économique et qui devrait d'autant plus
des partenaires parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de liens qui nous unissent donc
apparemment tout va mieux
évidemment jean yves le drian tient ce
discours parce que c'est la nouvelle
position de la france emmanuel macron
l'a affirmé clairement le 27 août
dernier au moment de la conférence des
ambassadeurs qui réunit tous les hauts
diplomates de notre pays je crois qu'il
nous faut construire une nouvelle
architecture de confiance et de sécurité
en europe parce que le continent
européen ne sera jamais stable ne sera
jamais en sécurité si nous ne pas s'y
fier ont pas et ne clarifions pas nos
relations avec la russie
ça n'est pas l'intérêt de certains de
nos alliés soyons clairs avec ce sujet
et certains d'ailleurs nous pousserons
toujours avoir plus de sanctions parce
que c'est leur intérêt
quand bien même ce sont nos amis mais ça
n'est pas le nôtre très profondément
ça peut aller c'est une vieille histoire
les relations franco russes avant
c'était sympa ce que les réussites et
communistes donc cette vidéo c'était nos
ennemis
maintenant c'est plus compliqué quelques
mois j'avais l'impression que au
contraire la réussite au banc des
accusés dans discours mac rognant elle
faisait partie
poutine s'était le mauvaise élève de
l'occident alors en plus macron c'est
quelqu'un de très brillant sur plan de
la rhétorique mais pas toujours très
convaincant quand il dit que les rues si
la russie est européenne
que la russie c'est la patrie des
lumières c'est pas très crédible c'est
donc on peut quand même moi je suis
plutôt je veux dire on peut pas se
réjouir d'une cette espèce de
russophobie qui a qui a traversé un
petit peu les esprits à un moment donné
donc je vois pas j'ai pas d'objection
sur ce rapprochement
le président de la république j'ai eu à
des fidèles seat sr craintes nos alliés
alors il ya les américains mais il ya
aussi d'autres pays d'europe comme la
pologne ou les pays baltes qui
historiquement ont de bonnes raisons de
se méfier de la russie mais nous c'est
pas notre cas a priori est ce que est ce
qu'on a des raisons de ne pas être ami
avec les russes on est typiquement
français c'est pour ça qu'on trouve que
c'est aussi bipolaire je trouve ou qu'on
parle en termes d'amis ou d'ennemis
c'est très affectif comme vocable déjà
et c'est qu'on se situe toujours pour
raisonner de façon un peu distancé comme
ça sur l'éthique de conviction
quels sont vos rapports quelles sont les
grandes alliances quels sont les grands
principes qui fait qu'on doit se rallier
ou non à la russie à nos alliés et c est
je pense que là on a une illustration
parfaite que même la france n'est pas du
tout sur une éthique de conviction quand
bien même la rhétorique utilisent ces
mots là mais quand on est sur une
éthique de responsabilité quel est
l'intérêt pour la france quel est
l'intérêt de ce sommet
normandie et que la rhétorique reste
encore du côté de la conviction mais que
la réalité et dans l'éthique de
responsabilité tant et tant mieux non
[ __ ] mais parce que c'est ça un peu d
intérêt de nous et on doit pas être sur
le registre affectif l'affectivité elle
va pour tous maintenant il faut de
l'émotion pour tous on avait président
qui dit j'aime les entreprises j'aime la
finance je n'aime pas la finance et les
rues sont des amis les autres sont des
amis on a l'impression d'une grande
fraternité mais on ré on doit rester sur
le registre diplomatique et pas du tout
affectif et tant pis maxime des gayettes
si les russes sont pas toujours
complètement dans les clous en ukraine
ou en crimée ce serait la consécration
de la realpolitik
moi j'ai pensé au contraire à penser
qu'aujourd'hui
surtout dans un moment où en fait
le président de la république multiplie
les stratégies en zigzag et en bilatéral
d'ailleurs dans dans le domaine
diplomatique moi je préfère qu'on parle
en termes de principes en termes de
stratégie objectivement la stratégie de
la france depuis quelques mois
maintenant je la vois pas effectivement
il ya chercher quand même assez étonnant
que il ya un rapprochement parce que
c'est comme ça que ce évoqué avec la
russie aujourd'hui alors même que
poutine même dans son pays et pour va
dire pas dans une position forcément
aussi forte qu'il ya quelques mois que
on assure toute une série de sujets
prenons par exemple la question du
réchauffement climatique est bien vu que
on a effectivement est justement
dénoncer ce qui se passe au brésil avec
la demande d'intervention sur les flancs
d'amazonie m'enfin lui défend sibérie
sur lequel on va dire que la réponse du
pouvoir
de moscou était tardif tardive pardon
donc on voit bien donc moi je suis assez
étonné que y ait ce changement de pied
si un changement depuis aujourd'hui par
ailleurs je crois que c'est parce que
emmanuel macron a construit ses
relations diplomatiques
fondamentalement non pas par des espaces
de régulation qui s'articule avec des
principes ce qui empêche pas d'avoir des
intérêts mais autour et bien de jeu
d'acteur et donc passant de l'un à
l'autre de manière plus ou moins
particulière suivant les sujets
d'ailleurs quelquefois faisant des
stratégies peu gagnante puisque beaucoup
de des partenaires de la france ont été
rapidement mises en difficulté on peut
penser évidemment à merkel ou à d'autres
jeux moi je crois et j'attends en tout
cas de la france qu'elle évoque une
vodka kevin veut qu'elle exprime une
vraie stratégie et que on retrouve quand
même un peu de sens dans les
institutions qui existent de discussions
et de régulation et qui nous permettra
peut-être aussi d'avoir un peu de
cohérence dans nos principes
parce que moi personnellement j'ai du
mal à suivre je veux bien croire que les
intérêts de la france évolue à travers
les mois mais je ne suis pas certain
c'est comme ça qu'on construit et bien
une véritable stratégie qu'elle soit en
terme de fonds et de valeurs qu'elle
soit en termes économiques moi je pense
juste un mot parce que je pense que la
stratégie c'est exactement le contraire
c'est là que vous dites que la stratégie
tic dans la stratégie au sens on suit un
principe je pense pas du tout au
contraire c'est faire des zigzags des
allers-retours pascal stratège sait
faire avec les aléas les contingences
les intérêts du moment
et sinon on n'est pas dans la tradition
on est dans le programme mais ça c'est
la vision un peu anciennes à mon sens de
la politique où il faut exécuter un
programme
et là on dirait il ya un sens si un cap
mais non est stratège c'est justement
être capable de changer de voie aussi ça
veut pas dire être dispersées mais être
capable en fonction des contingences du
moment de d'orienter ou de réorienter sa
politique on navigue à vue quand
on est dans cette problématique où il
yad'un côté de trump dans cette
conférence des ambassadeurs moi j étais
25% de ce discours a été liée à cette
redéfinition du modèle occidental
repenser toutes les grandes lignes de
partage du monde contemporain avec d'un
côté la menace entre guillemets chinoise
l'autre côté la menace des tweets du
trump est donc au milieu il ya une
espèce de grand ensemble si on s'accorde
pas pour macron c'est évident que là il
ya un partenariat extrêmement
volontariste parce que mon avis il est
un peu comme vous disiez un peu à
contretemps de sa profonde méfiance
il a dû voir il avait la crimée il a vu
l'ukraine il a vu à la syrie il ya dix
sujets qui nous met réellement en
belligérance avec les russes sur le plan
même symbolique affectif psychologique
mais pourtant ils tentent ce pari là
parce qu'il se dit pas non c'est la
seule façon que nous on a de tirer notre
épingle du jeu et c'est un bon
spéculateur c'est un bon banquier bakr
en asie la chine devienne actionnaire
ils acceptent ils achètent les actions à
la baisse vous avez raison sur le fait
que poutine est affaibli en ce moment
dans son pays il a eu un vote ce week
end a cédé valoir accord des élections
locales y avait 17 % de participation
deux heures avant la fermeture des des
urnes hier soir à 18h20 c'est ça veut
dire que plus personne ne s'occupe de
politique à moscou et dans sa et dans la
périphérie moscou donc c'est vraiment un
pays qui aujourd'hui n'est plus vraiment
qui continuent à soutenir poutine parce
qu'elle a peur profonde
voilà la population russe a profondément
peur du monde qui vient et des menaces
qu'on lui que la propagande lui brandit
comme des menaces mais concrètement
poutine il sent que son économie est
fragile très fragile sa démographie -0
7% cette année
c'est vraiment une population qui
vieillit et qui se renouvelle pas et
donc il n'y a pas beaucoup dynamique et
lui-même et affaiblissement politique
donc
macron achète l'action russe en baisse
d'accord il a bien entendez que moi je
ne pense pas les relations
internationales en tant que banquier
d'affaires mais ça chacun connaissait
que je préfère faire de penser en tant
que politique et donc à partir de
valeurs et je j'ai comme le soupçon de
penser je sais que ça compte peu mais
que
les français et nos concitoyens à un
moment donné il aime bien avoir un peu
de lisibilité de vision et les latitudes
en tout cas la politique internationale
qui aujourd'hui développée par emmanuel
maintenant je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle nous permettra de faire ça elle
permet de faire des arrangements
temporaires
je suis pas certain qu'elle dessine un
dessin pour la france et pour l'europe
pendant sa police que vous pensez qu'il
ya une part de mise en scène personnelle
des manuels macron dans ce côté je suis
avec tout ce qui compte
et tant pis si c'est pas très lisible je
pense oui je pense que certainement mais
c'est vrai qu' un côté pratique dans la
stratégie ce que vous appelez la
stratégie macro mais vous parliez de
valeur et à l'affectivité qui compte
énormément la russie un des fantasmes
des angoisses des russes est toujours
d'être isolé une certaine manière ils
ont cette espèce autrefois il était
encerclée
quand il était le système soviétique et
d'être isolé ou méprisé de l'occident
bon il ya aussi ce qui compte c'est à
dire une certaine franco francophilie
leur part il ya quand même des liens
affectifs entre la france et la russie
plus en plus jour qui ont toujours
existé et qui nous pas poutine ses liens
doivent être entretenues donc en dehors
de tout machiavélisme
moi j'y crois pas aux valeurs dans la
diplomatie je suis plutôt du côté
machiavélien et du côté des intérêts au
général de gaulle en 1944 il est allé
voir staline quels étaient les valeurs
de staline c'était rien c'était leur
antithétiques à celle de la france de la
france libre donc en dehors des en
dehors du domaine des intérêts il ya le
domaine affectif je pense que le monde
orthodoxe et en particulier le monde
russe est plutôt francophile
culturellement et c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas négligeable
non mais je ne parle pas de poutine je
parle des rustines un jour il parle il
passera qui n'y passera je parle des
russes et faisant poutine a remis une
affectivité mais les russes sont
certainement les amis de la france
là on parle du pouvoir russe
la question a été un peu biaisé si vous
me permettez 20 ans la réunion dont vous
parliez de le drian et ils se sont
retrouvés nos deux ministres à nous
devant les deux mêmes qui à 20 ans hier
c'était le même les à défense et le
bimini affaires étrangères c'est
impressionnant donc autour de poutine ya
quelque chose d'immobile de glace et de
complètement masqué même tresques et
donc sa force c'est d'avoir cette
realpolitik 7 ce rapport de force en
permanence et d'être très sûr de sa
force quoi et alors que nous on est tout
le temps en train d'essayer de soi que
jouer avec des verres l'affectivité
wallace et à leur tête des fins tel
rouleau compresseur
ça me semble vraiment aimé mauvais part
je parle d'affectivité je parle de liens
culturels
je parle de kadhafi qui suscite et je
parle pas de sentiment je parle de liens
culturels et j'ai l'impression que le
côté lien va leur affectivité même dans
les entreprises on le voit très bien et
un peu obsolète ces sont des valeurs
assez décadente maintenant les gens en
vie d'intérêt d'expérience de mai le
sentiment d'appartenir d'avoir des
valeurs communes
j'ai l'impression mais à mon grand
regret je suis pas contre cette idée
mais que c'est totalement décadent
décadent ouais non décadent vous dite
catch zéro absolu est obsolète
ah oui d'accord mais pas des cadeaux
mais que autre kaka du coin les rues
sont ils vraiment des amis quand vous
êtes très partagés
le cher internaute 54% nous disent oui
et 46% non c'est vrai que c'est l'un des
points clés maxime dégraisser y at il
encore une menace russe certains disent
que la crim est toujours été reçu et
qu'il est normal que poutine dé
récupérer qu'il veut juste être
respectée mais que non ils ci n'est plus
un mythe de la russie n'est pas un
danger pour nous je suis pas d'accord
avec ça mais inversion de propos
regardons l'ensemble des grandes sujet
on va dire internationaux auxquels la
france mais aussi l'europe et le monde
sont confrontés et regardons si et bien
le pouvoir russe actuelle que doit être
un point d'appui ou par un point d'appui
parce que
je développe j'ai développé tout à
l'heure une logique de vision et donc de
coalition qui soit articulée autour de
principes ça n'empêche pas évidemment de
regarder aussi ce qui se passe ailleurs
vous voyez que sur le sujet du
réchauffement climatique sur la question
aujourd'hui de la montée des populistes
de la préservation de la démocratie sur
le retour d'un multi une forme de
multilatéralisme qui me semble
indispensable parce qu'on va pas
répondre aujourd'hui aux grands enjeux
du monde en continuant enfin après c'est
des choix je sais que d'autres d'autres
stratégies
d'autres appels au retour de l'état
nation j'aurais tendance à penser que
même si c'était c'est comment c'est une
longue parenthèse il serait peut-être
bon de revenir à une réaffirmation de
d'outils de régulation au niveau
international sur tous ces sujets là je
ne pense pas voilà que la russie soit
notre point d'appui premier et surtout
indique juste que la russie même si on
doit travailler avec eux si on veut être
dans le multilatéralisme
il faut bien comprendre que ce qu'on va
dire est ce qu'est ce que dit
aujourd'hui où le changement de pied du
gouvernement peut apparaître en
contradiction avec d'autres principes et
au bout d'un moment vous mais vous
prenez les pieds dans le tapis c'est à
dire que vous pouvez pas expliquer que
notre sujet numéro un c'est d'afrique
qu' il ya une question centrale qui est
la montée des populismes qu'il faut qu
on réaffirme aujourd'hui les instances
internationales
y compris l'onu et dans le même temps et
bien ne pas réagir quand il ya des camps
la démocratie est bafouée en russie ne
pas réagir quand et bien
les pas notre rôle de matane écoute de
women démocratie en fait vous avez
raison le mot affectivité n'est pas
adaptée c'est pas ce mot là que je
voulais utiliser
je voulais utiliser le terme d'affinités
je pense qu'il existe des affinités
entre les peuples et les cultures et il
ya une constante
il ya une affinité on pourra en discuter
parce que c'est un véritable débat entre
le monde russe orthodoxe et le monde
français c'est à dire que c'est pas
entre l'occident et la russie s'est il
ya une permanence de la russie
d'ailleurs c'est un peu c'était pas de
vue du général de jeu propose connaît ce
dernier mois nos internautes à broc
nitot qui nous dit attention la russie
le seul pays du monde à reconnaître et
soutenir plusieurs zones
indépendantistes et à les occuper
militairement on pense évidemment à la
partie est l'ukraine en tout cas je
suppose que c'est ce que brody toi à
l'esprit et l'union européenne ne fait
pas ça nous dit il la russie cherche à
imposer à un monopole sur les
approvisionnements énergétiques de
l'europe occidentale ne faut pas se
leurrer et babineau considère lui que il
s'agit de comme c'est la com du
gouvernement macron encore une fois